sie sind himmelsstürmer wollen einmal in
den weltraum fliegen vielleicht sogar
einmal auf dem mars stück die
europäische weltraumorganisation wählte
diese sechs jungen europäer aus italien
frankreich england dänemark und
deutschland unter tausenden bewerbern
aus
ich freue mich wirklich darauf auch sehr
unterschiedliche sachen zu lernen
die wissenschaftliche aspekte die
technischen aspekte die über alle
aspekte die sozialen kompetenzen aspekte
also man man hat wirklich billig die
gelegenheit sich 360° auszubilden und
das ist eigentlich ein anteil von
astronauten leben das mir so entspricht
sachen auf die ich besonders freut
natürlich so sagen wir fliegen lernen
das hat mich schon immer fasziniert ich
bin ja als fallschirmspringer auch schon
ein bisschen näher mit dem kontakt
gekommen aber selbst ein flugzeug zu
steuern ist natürlich weiß auch dass ich
mich riesig freude dann russisch werden
wir lernen das wird natürlich eine
herausforderung das bestimmt nicht eine
einfache sachen wird aber es ist auch
nicht wahrheit die menschen immer sehr
gefallen hat und die ich schon immer
wirklich gern gelernt hätte deswegen
dass zwei sachen auf die ich mich
besonders freude
cape canaveral in florida das ist der
startplatz für weltraum träume das vier-
bis fünfjährige training beginnt für die
abc-schützen der raumfahrt mit zeit
ziehen als reiseführer fungierte
erfahrene holländischer astronaut und re
körpers auf einladung der nasa lernen
die jungen einen der zukünftigen
arbeitsplätze kennen das kennedy space
center
höhepunkt soll am abend der geplante
start des space shuttle sein
mit blick vom vip zelt aus
cape canaveral heimat des space shuttles
seit jahrzehnten lebt man hier von und
mit der raumfahrt
es ist ein unaufgeregter menschenschlag
auch an tagen wie diesem einem launch
day seinem starttag des space shuttle
hier ist man aufgeregt wie das wohl ist
doch oben im cockpit von hier aus haben
die esa schüler einen besonders guten
blick auf die raumfähre discovery selbst
gestandenen wissenschaftlern und
kampfpiloten nötig diese szene respekt
ab noch können sie zwei jahre von ihrem
ersten flug aber gedanken kann man sich
ja schon mal machen
wer mit wem ihr meistens als es als
pflicht waren nicht mit einem anderen
zusammen weil der esa astronaut ihm der
einzige europäer antwort ist würde man
dann mit bussen zusammenbringen wir
möchten natürlich im moment nicht ganz
so realistisch dass man zusammen pflegt
als europäische astronauten
normalerweise ist man doch alleine mit
eine internationale crew unterwegs
wenn das doch passiert würde ich mir
natürlich vor allem mit jedem fall
meinen neuen kollegen zu klingen
auch er und rekers hat hier mal
gestanden als junge anwärter nun lässt
der lehrer die jungen antreten zum
erinnerungsfoto auch das posen will
schließlich gelernt sein rundgang durch
die heiligen hallen des kennedy space
center an den wänden vergangene
missionen stumme zeugen große abenteuer
heute werden hier die 69 esa astronauten
offiziell begrüßt noch sind sie
touristen in diesen riesigen hallen
werden die labors für zukünftige
missionen gebaut und gewartet hightech
aus allen 18 asse nationen nur die
besten dürfen hier damit arbeiten
andré küppers selber arzt zu den
voraussetzungen für den astronauten
beruf
was wir brauchen sagt er ist interesse
für wissenschaft und technologie
wenn sie das interesse entwickelt haben
ist es eigentlich egal woher sie kommen
ob ingenieur testpilot oder biologe
hauptsache sie haben sich mit
wissenschaft und technik beschäftigt das
ist alles noch ein wenig weiter weg
alexander gerst der 32 jährige
geophysiker steht am beginn seiner
karriere noch darf gestaunt werden
später einmal wird ihm all die
milliarden schwere technik all das
wissen darum ein ständiger begleiter
sein
bei allen sechs schwingt auch ein stück
idealismus mit der mensch arbeitet um
sich selber zu verbessern
das ist das motto systeme die man
bedienen können muss zu jeder tages und
nachtzeit vielleicht gerade aufgewacht
ist man ist ja immer ein bisschen unter
druck zu zeigen dass man gut genug ist
ja das schöne daran wenn das natürliche
ein schönes gefühl zu wissen dass man
muss jeden tag ein bisschen besser
werden und ich glaube das ist ja auch
das ist für die pilotin christopher red
i ist das der normalfall
im cockpit eines kampfflugzeugs arbeitet
sie täglich an der physischen und
psychischen grenzen
es wirkt schon fast wie ironie rund um
das kennedy space center gibt es keinen
größeren feind der modernen technik als
die gewitterwolke wenn sie sich am
horizont auftürmt gerät der
shuttle-start in gefahr
an die launen der natur haben sich die
menschen hier gewöhnt sie hoffen einfach
dass die raumfähre doch noch abhebt
die fans des space-shuttle treffen sich
hier in der sunset bar public viewing
beim mambo und margarita hoffentlich
geht heute alles gut
im pressezentrum akkreditieren sich die
ersten journalisten für den start von
hektik keine spur
es sieht nach einem ganz normalen
arbeitstag aus die entscheidende frage
an den wetter verantwortlichen hier vor
ort wie entwickelt sich das wetter wir
haben viele blitze draußen gesehen
offizier sagt uns dass sie ist gerade
mit einigen gewittern in der nähe des
startplatzes zu tun haben
momentan stehen die lampen für den
shuttle-start aufruf außerdem beobachten
sie schlechtes wetter das aus dem osten
heranzieht sie haben schon einige blitze
gesichtet momentan können sie eigentlich
nur die weitere entwicklung ab die
astronauten anwärter auf dem weg in die
sogenannte processing facility
hier gehen die shuttle nach jedem flug
in die inspektion
sogar uhren und ringe müssen die
besucher ablegen
jedes noch so kleine fremde teilchen
kann beim start zur katastrophe führen
zurzeit steht hier die atlantis die
jungen astronauten sind sichtlich
beeindruckt von sicherheitsaufwand der
jahren ende ihr leben schützt und das
sind die kacheln die das shuttle beim
wiedereintritt in die atmosphäre vor dem
vorglühen bewahren
25.000 keramikplatten jeder einzelne
wird eingehend geprüft und im zweifel
ersetzt
alexander gerst jetzt nicht mehr tourist
und noch nicht astronaut weiß um die
gefahren der astronauten zwei shuttle
hat die nasa durch unfälle verloren
ich bin eigentlich nicht nicht sehr
risikofreudiger mensch habe ich gemerkt
ich wirklich analysieren das risiko um
mich rum die gefahren wenn ich ungefähr
abschätzen kann
dann wäre ich das risiko ein und dann
bin ich auch bereit das risiko
einzugehen wenn es sich dann wert ist
wenn das was dabei rauskommt das
rechtfertigt das ist dann schon okay
aber ich wie gesagt ich denke dass ich
mich da gar nicht so weit von anderen
menschen unterscheide ich denke das
macht jeder so es ist vielleicht nur
nicht so ganz so offensichtlich wie
fühlt sich ihre lebensversicherung an
der nasa-ingenieur erlaubt dem nachwuchs
was sonst streng verboten ist
die kacheln extreme leichtgewichte mit
nur rund vier kilo pro stück kalten
temperaturen zwischen minus 200 und plus
1000 grad celsius aus noch vier stunden
bis zum statt
rund um das gelände weiträumige
polizeisperren wir sind etwa 25 km vom
sogenannten launch pad dem startplatz
entfernt
noch näher heran kommen nur die die bei
einer nasa lotterie tickets für prime
viewing areas also ausgewiesene
aussichtspunkte ersteigern kunden
familie gates hatte kein glück
vater geht erzählt uns von seinem besuch
in der riesigen nasa montagehalle seine
freunde würden dort arbeiten eigentlich
schaue er sich den staat ja immer von
titusville aus an
aber hier sei es doch schöner weil man
eben den shuttle-start direkt über das
wasser hinwegsehen können mag kommt aus
amsterdam der hobbyfotograf ist schon
zum zweiten mal hier
beim ersten besucher der den start der
raumfähre verpasst und bei der ticket
lotterie hatte er auch kein glück mag
erzählt uns dass man sehr sehr schnell
sein müsste bei der versteigerung
innerhalb von zwei minuten sei alles weg
bei der nasa wird jetzt fieberhaft
beobachtet und gerechnet schon ein
kleines gewitter über dem cache kann den
zig millionen teuren start verhindern
alles steht bereit nur noch zwei stunden
die redakteure vom internetsender
spaceflight punkt com gehen auf sendung
unter den raumfahrt fans sind diese drei
kult es heißt niemand löchert die nasa
offiziellen so fachkundig wie sie noch
stehen die startchancen gut sagt der
reporter von fox news
auch die großen sender haben sich vor
der berühmten countdown uhr aufgebaut
und berichten rund um die uhr über den
stand der dinge
über monitore sehen die journalisten
genau was in der raumkapsel vor sich
geht gerade wird kommandant rick
sturckow an seinen sitz geschnallt die
ganzen abläufe sind trainiert worden
trotzdem geht anders sozusagen noch mal
das leben durch den kopf mir ist
eigentlich nicht mein leben durch den
kopf gegangen sein wie es eher durch den
kopf gegangen
wie sitzt mein nachbar hat mein nachbar
alles in ordnung habe ich alles in
ordnung
wo muss ich als erstes ran was stecke
ich wohin weil es sind es sieht alles so
grob aus aber wir haben viele viele
kleine dinge die einer richtigen stelle
in der richtigen tasche obenauf oder
unten vergraben sind und ich muss mal
durchgehen was im falle von welchem
ereignis ich an welches zuerst muss man
ist wirklich sehr beschäftigt man hat
vielleicht mal eine minute
vielleicht mal 30 sekunden und da denkt
man er natürlich auch von draußen wie
geht es meiner familie sieht sie zu sind
sie jetzt mittlerweile in den
besucherraum geht es ihnen gut
und natürlich was kommt in den nächsten
zwei stunden was kommt in den ersten
minuten der schwerelosigkeit das für
jeden anders an schlegel ist ein
erfahrener astronaut der 58 jährige war
schon zweimal im weltall bei seinem
letzten einsatz betreute er das
europäische forschungslabor columbus
heute lebt hans schlegel in houston hier
am cape kennt er noch jeden seine
aktuelle mission die betreuung der
jungen esa astronauten während der
ausbildung
anderthalb stunden vor dem start ist die
spannung unter den journalisten mit
händen zu greifen
die wetteraussichten waren den ganzen
tag über durchwachsen niemand weiß was
kommt gerüchte über einen startabbruch
machen schon die runde der wette
offizier erzählt uns dass sie ein gebiet
von zehn meilen rund um den stadtplatz
besonders beobachten
hier darf es unter keinen umständen
gewitter geben da würde der staat sofort
abgebrochen
auch die weitere umgebung wird auf dem
radarschirm genau analysiert um mögliche
heranziehende schlechtwetterfronten
rechtzeitig zu erkennen
ein letztes hoffen dann die gewissheit
startabbruch mal wieder hat das wetter
der nasa ein schnippchen geschlagen
nicht nur die astronauten erleben in
diesen sekunden ein wechselbad der
gefühle
auch für die berichterstatter endet ein
spannender abend je mit dem
wetterbericht langsam legt sich die
anspannung viele haben hier stundenlang
ausgeharrt für heute vergebens die
enttäuschung ist manchem anzusehen